Hồi nyi, I.B. I.C. Tuyên Hải Phòng Thú đơ 1 lắm Tee U.S.D. đầu tiên trong giai đoạn hợp nhất.
Xin ra từ ngày 1 lắm đến ngày 18, năm 2018, hồi ít là thứ 3 của ở Đồng Thu Bình Thí Hoạch
Appet, I.B. I.C. Tuyên Hải Thuyên phố Hải Phòng. Đừng ký vọng sẽ mở ra lần sống đầu tiên mới, với tổn tại
chỉ cảm thấy với móc 1 lắm Tee U.S.D. chủ yêu vào phát sử an công nghiệp và phát triển hạt tận cảnh miếng.
Sự kẻ thú hút tự tham dự của khoảng 1 liên 2 trong đại biểu trong đào các hai chăm năm
người khác cúp đe tự 2 mốt nền kinh tế thành phía nảm ảm ảm ảnh ảnh ước tổn tâm và cảm thấy hợp
các sông tổn gối Việt Nam là chung và hải phòng nói dân. Nửa bật trong trộn hợp đồng là hồi nghị
xuất kến đầu tự 2 phòng hai nghìn thông chăm ai lắm với chủ đe. Hải phòng viện đến chính lượng
của tí Green Moon đây là tìm đe thành phố dưới kiệu mối trường đầu tư chính xác yếu đã vật các liệt tổn
đồng tân nghiệp trong vòng hồi nước. Kêu ông Lê Trung Kênh chừng bán có li của tí tế hai phòng
kênh phố sẽ xong đầy trứng nhận đầu tư và tí kế biến bản kinh giữa hợp tác cho bà miệ hài dự án
bà bệnh thoát tốt với tổn mối tổn mối lắm tí USD trong đó hôm mối tí USD sẽ được lộ tư và các dự án
phát chế thạ tần công nghiệp trong liệu trọng liệu tân trọng mũ phúc chẳng dương phà bên sinbài tinh lắng và các tổn